même si la fondation du doute est bien
situé à blois
la touraine connaît aussi le doute dans
les oeuvres d'art public au privé
l'exemple le plus connu ce sont les
célèbres caravage de la ville de loos
et
tout commence en 2004 lorsque pascal dû
puiser adjoint au maire chargé de la
culture
les dévoilant un conservateur des
monuments historiques la direction
régionale des affaires culturelles fait
classer les tableaux en urgence et
impose une protection par vitre blindée
s'en suit une bataille d'experts
mais nous sommes à loches en france ça
c'est la france c'est toujours trop beau
quand les deux histoires arrivée ne
peuvent arriver que dans les lieux
prestigieux
ça ne peut être annoncé que par bio de
personnalités et là malheureusement les
services de l'état demandait que ce soit
jean jacques descamps maire de loches
petite ville de la touraine une ville
hautement admirable mais petite ville
quand même c'était pas possible qu'on
puisse trouver deux caravage à loches
donc voilà après la noce officiel qui
nous a été demandé de faire
on a demandé à l'homme absolument
prestigieux en matière de l'art qui
s'appelle pierre rosenberg qui à n'en
pas douter est un grand ponte en matière
de peinture sauf qui n'a jamais été
spécialiste de caravage mais nicolas
poussin un journaliste est allé sonner à
sa porte au lendemain de cette annonce
et il a dit mais non pas des sommes
peut-être que des copies des originaux
on les connaît ils sont à l'envers ya
peu de salles à partir de là la messe
était dite pour le monde de l'art en
effet le losc ne pouvait pas avoir de
peinture originale de caravage est là
depuis ce temps-là y bien il ya des
doutes lundi du permanent que les grands
de ce monde entretiennent mais on a eu
quand même
catherine public est une grande
spécialiste de caravage qui est venue
elle vidéo aux etats unis elle est venue
des états unis pour voir si tableau elle
a été extrêmement séduite elle trouvait
au regard des documents historiques et
scientifiques plutôt qui étaient là qui
avait pas de raison que ce ne soit pas
version autographe de ses tableaux
pourtant les visites se multiplient
mais pas celle des gens qui comptent
dans la procédure d'attribution et les
détails d'authenticité s'accumulent ce
col bleu avait les blancs étaient peints
par l'artiste qui a réalisé ce cette
peinture est autant que l'on puisse le
savoir quand un copiste réalise la copie
d'un tableau ne s'autorise aucune
modification
seul celui qui a créé l'oeuvre peut se
permettre
lorsqu'il pas une seconde fois un
tableau il peut se permettre une
variante et puis radiographie a prouvé
que dans ces deux tableaux il ya des
incisions seul caravage à cette époque
la penne de la sorte aucun dessin
préparatoire
une vingtaine décisions marquées dans la
pâte fraîche et il attaqué et bientôt en
deux tableaux il y à ces fameuses
incision alors voilà la réponse
appartient aux spécialistes
à une condition c'est que les
spécialistes acceptent de venir faire
leur boulot
jean-paul baissière est un expert
tourangeau parmi les plus réputés
d'europe
il a notamment sorti de l'ombre une
offre unique originale de ronsard
membres de jurys de thèse d'experts
libraire lors de l'ultime épreuve de cet
examen il sort de sa poche ce livre daté
xvième siècle et le soumet à la sagacité
des étudiants alors est il vrai ou faux
alors d'une part ya différentes sortes
de fou il ya le faux fait pour tromper
il ya le faux fait pour imiter il ya le
faux fais pour le plaisir et on peut
facilement avec peu de moyens récupérer
deux ouvrages incomplet du le moteur est
une âme qui sont naturellement et en
faire un seul
à condition naturellement que tous les
feux gay et la même même coloris etc etc
dans ce cas on lave on lave les deux
livres on récupère les feuillets
manquant sur un des ouvrages et on les
place dans l'autre et on fait une
rupture entre guillemets dit pastiche
voilà alors d'où peut bien de doute
certaine souplesse voyez ici dans les
dents les morts c'est trop souple un
ouvrage du 16e qui s'est ouvert peut
être 2000 soit depuis le 16ème aurait
ici des petits problèmes de maurs
l'appel des morts alors pourquoi s'il
n'y a pas de problème demeure parce que
le cuir lui même est un cuir du 16e
siècle récupérer donc sur and in folio
du 16e siècle qui était très incomplet
qui n'est pas l'intérêt mais il a pris
donc une partie du plat de la reliure et
donc il l'est il a gardé une certaine
souplesse et il n'est pas du tout
fatigué il n'est pas du tout donc ce
cuir vient effectivement donc d'un plat
d'un livre du 16e en revanche le dow est
très bien fait les fers qui sont là ont
été faits spécialement donc par
d'ambroise sur commande
tous à la santé des petits faire quand
qui sont réellement 16e il ya tout un
stock de fer 16e il a acheté depuis 40
ans
la sir est une cire parfaite qui a été
décollés sur un livre à la cire
complètement bousillé qu'il avait chez
lui tout est bon sauf qu'il est faux la
rumeur est fausse et parfois le fossat
vite dans le monde du vrai durant la
deuxième moitié du 19e siècle michel
chasles polytechnicien et membre de
l'académie des sciences est au sommet de
sa notoriété
originaire d'eure-et-loir il reçoit un
jour un autre beauceron de livres 1
lucas qui lui proposent des manuscrits
originaux originaux dans tous les sens
du terme
alors il sort d'une petite mallette
minable donc que des papiers tout
froissé et la chatte 30 vraiment des
nues ils n'en reviennent pas alors nous
à part quelques cas être de pascal
quelques lettres de d'écart at il voit
par exemple une lettre adressée par
jésus-christ à marie madeleine dans un
français du 16e et qui coûtait qu'est ce
que c'est que ça et alors donc que
monsieur vrai lucas puisqu'il s'agit de
lui raconte donc ces lettres ont toutes
une histoire de la fin du xvème des
beaux débuts 16e durable et découvre
donc cette mine extraordinaire et
transcrit en france et donc de son temps
en france et rabelaisien tous ces
documents et donc il a sous les yeux
donc les documents transcrit donc pour
jésus-christ et c'est à dire par
rabelais évidemment dans le cette lettre
de jésus-christ marie madeleine
évidemment cette lettre du poids de
socrate à pythagore évidemment à cette
lettre donc de jules césar à
vercingétorix et caetera et j'en passe
et des meilleurs elles sont des faux
de livres 1 l'udc a réalisé plus de 30
mille faux manuscrits et a été par trois
fois condamné à la pise
à
dans cet étui de micro-ordinateurs
enveloppé comme un nourrisson est
toujours manié avec des gants un tableau
de faibles dimensions peut-être d'une
valeur inestimable
depuis des années il fait l'objet de
recherche et d'expertisé
il pourrait être l'oeuvre de deux génies
de la peinture
j'essaie de rebondir sur des hypothèses
qui ont été mises de la rencontre
possible de jérôme bosch et l'honneur de
20,6 a déjà été évoquée par des
historiens d'art connu on n'a pas la
preuve et j'essaye avec les oeuvres
connues de l'un et l'autre de faire des
rapprochements iconographique c'est à
dire de montrer que certains motifs de
bosch ont été repris par léonard de
vinci réciproquement et notamment de
façon assez surprenante cet éléphant là
qu'on trouve dans la partie droite
en fait il apparaît dans un tableau
dans le jardin des délices dans le
panneau latéral droit si je m'abuse de
jérôme bosch
et puis il ya quelques années maurizio
serra chimie en réflecteurs graphie
infrarouge a trouvé dans l'adoration des
mages de derrière de vinci un éléphant
si on rapproche ces trois motifs là il
ya des correspondances voilà évidente
ici vous avez un motif typiquement beau
chien sera pas se monter sur un cheval
aux allures d'oiseaux leur d'ailleurs
puisqu'il a un autre un autre oiseau
c'est typiquement beau chien c'est un
motif qu'on retrouve dans une tentation
de saint-antoine bien connue de bosch
alors c'est pas traiter de tout à fait
de la même manière mais c'est un motif
beau chien et qui a été mentionné comme
tel par des grands les grands historiens
d'art puis en regardant avec attention
la partie droite du panneau de bois
peint on découvre un paysage
anthropomorphes c'est-à-dire un buisson
qui dessine également le profil de
leonardo masse
donc on tombe sur un profil de
vieillards qui est situé voilà dans
cette dans cette partie là alors
évidemment qui est renversé mais il
suffit de retourner le tableau pour
mieux le voir est en fait de façon
surprenante si on rapproche avec ce
fameux portraits autoportraits turan
bernard de vinci au niveau des sourcils
au niveau du nez au niveau de la barben
on retrouve des trade
de similarités à ces similitudes à c'est
assez surprenant
alors voilà est-ce que c'est un hommage
de brescia léonard de vinci est ce que
c'est un travail fait à quatre mains ou
est-ce que c'est simplement un
admirateur de gérante bauchi léonard de
vinci qui après leur mort aurait voulu
rendre un hommage à ces deux personnes
loin de léonard de vinci et du clos lucé
lorsque nous rencontrons philippe
rouillac
il est en compagnie excellente d'une
oeuvre peut-être d'andy warhol une
sérigraphie niké kom la série des
portraits multiples de marilyn monroe de
mao tsé toung retouché à la gouache mais
le fait que ces retouches soit dans le
plus pur style d'andy warhol est ce
suffisant pour lui attribuer l'oeuvre on
retrouve ces grands coups de brosse qui
agrémentent et qui colorise d'une
manière extrêmement gay ce cette tête de
mickey ce qui nous pose le plus de
problème grâce à une l'eau c'est la
signature
vous voyez que la signature elle est en
noir en feutre et quant au regard de
près elle recourt ou une signature
antérieures en feutre gris et cette
signature en feutre gris on la retrouve
toujours dans les portraits de andy
warhol et dans celle de mickey non celui
qui aurait signé ça c'est celui qui a
fait une mise en couleur mais ce que
c'est andy warhol quand même faire un
faux on en fait toujours de trop c'est
un pastiche les pièces de monnaie sont
plus lourdes les bergères sont plus
aptes ans le cheval court et n'est pas
l'arrêt pourquoi on aurait redonné une
signature de when you're all qui
correspond exactement à la signature
colleau koné sur une signature
authentique
le mystère reste entier autre paramètre
l'origine et la traçabilité de l'oeuvre
la source est pur comme l'on dit un
membre de la famille propriétaire du
tableau collabora avec le célèbre
publiciste américain mais maintenant que
fait-on
nous allons d encadrer cette oeuvre pour
s'approcher du papier monnaie unique et
sensuelle que méprisant pour toucher
papier et voir si ce papier c'est celui
d'une sérigraphie qui est connu
ou c'est une vulgaire photos à partir
d'une sérigraphie connu
et puis on va toucher la matière mais
non on voit qu'il ya des reflets qu'il
ya du relief
donc c'est vraiment pas un cliché quoi
qu'il en soit c'est vraiment de la
peinture sur une sérigraphie
avec cette signature là tout est ouvert
qu'on nous allons ouvrir
on est aussi et chirurgiens du marché de
l'art dans quelques jours l'oeuvre
d'andy warhol sera d encadrer et rendre
à peut-être son bien il faudra encore du
temps pour comme henri thiot sert hacini
l'expert
davinci code fasse valider son hypothèse
sur le tableau bosch de grâce pendant
encore longtemps le livre pastiche du
16e siècle séduira les étudiants
stagiaires en ibérie et la ville de
loches soignera avec attention ces
caravage désormais juste contestées
mais au terme de ce voyage en touraine
une certitude
au delà du tout seul et vrai et
véritable le plaisir d'admirer